j'en viens maintenant à l'événement de
cet après midi au sénat l'audition de
vincent bolloré par la commission d'
enquête sur la concentration des médias
français l'homme d'affaires breton
possède canal+ europe 1 sans oublier ses
news ou le journal du dimanche il était
évidemment très attendue par les
sénateurs géant brasier ils étaient
attendus dont il représente la
concentration dans les médias vincent
bolloré qui a construit depuis une
vingtaine d'années un empire médiatique
était donc convoqué par la commission d'
enquête sur la concentration et le
pluralisme dans ce secteur d'entrée il
s'est défendu martelant que son groupe
n'est pas un géant médiatique notamment
face aux netflix amazon ou disney
contrairement à ce qui est écrit un peu
partout
nous sommes encore tout petit nous
progressons c'est vrai mais nous sommes
encore tout petit ce qu'on peut regarder
c'est que le vix 20-10 d'aujourd'hui est
infiniment plus petit que le livre un 10
10 à 20 ans et qui à l'époque en tout
cas ne posait aucun problème interrogé à
plusieurs reprises sur ses rachats et
sur les départs de nombreux journalistes
lors de sa prise en main le capitaine
d'industrie s'est défendu d'avoir
sacrifié des médias vous dites nous
avons détruit non nous avons construit
quand je suis arrivé chez canal
d'ailleurs j'ai dit je ne suis pas là la
cause de vos problèmes je suis là
conséquences de vos problèmes et
peut-être la solution relancé sur la
couleur politique aurait pris la chaîne
ses news vincent bolloré s'est défendu
oui il a fait venir eric zemmour sur son
antenne mais non il ne défend pas une
idéologie personnes 1 à l'ambition ou
l'intention ou l'erreur de d'essayer de
faire des chaînes d'opinion c'est pas
dans l'objectif du groupe vivendi canal
ça n'a pas d'importance ça n'a pas
d'intérêt se défendant rouge quand les
accusations vincent bolloré a aussi
précisé qu'il ne serait bientôt plus du
tout dans les instances dirigeantes
pas sûr que ces maigres explications et
éclairer la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale qui poursuivra ses travaux
demain avec l'audition tout aussi
attendu de bernard arnault
oui s'est présenté comme le paratonnerre
des différents groupes et médias dans
lequel bolloré le groupe bolloré un
départ on était avec alexandre poussard
ans en duplex depuis la salle des
conférences au sénat on a eu un peu le
sentiment que ça se transformait en duel
entre vincent bolloré et sénateur
socialiste david assouline un bon soir
thomas oui il ya clairement eu un face à
face entre vincent bolloré rapporteur de
la commission denquête david assouline
alors un face à face très polis mais
quand même david assouline qui a
commencé et bien son propos par une
énumération de tous les médias que
possédait le groupe bolloré une
énumération dans le détail ça a duré
cinq minutes c'est l oms a donné le
tournis on va écouter un extrait il y a
ces huit ses stars ses news studiocanal
my canal canal vod canal+ règle la
chaîne canal toutes ses variantes canal+
cinéma canal+ sport séries etc car plus
vietnam capuche ex canalsat canal
international calédonie canal+ karayi
plana le plus réunion canal+ afrique
vous avez aussi les multi thématiques
ciné-plus planète téléthon pee wee foot+
comédie infosport saison olympia tv
canal+ polska et puis aussi des médias
28% dans le secteur de la communication
trois chaînes de télévision italiennes
canale 5 italia 1 et rete 1,4 etc voilà
donc les faits assez saisissant c'est
une énumération qui a donc duré plus de
cinq minutes c'était voulu de la part du
rapporteur de la commission denquête
mais en même temps vincent bolloré avait
aussi très bien préparer sa réponse il
avait toute une série de slide documents
qu'il a affichée au sénateur pour
montrer que son groupe n'était pas si
gros que ça dans le monde et sur la
scène française il avait tellement de
cela aide qu'à un moment il s'est même
perdu dans ses fiches vincent bolloré il
voulait aussi diffusé un petit clip
vidéo aux sénateurs pour vraiment à les
convaincre ça ça n'a pas été possible
david assouline a dit que cette
commission denquête c'était pas une
salle de projection et puis le
rapporteur de la commission denquête est
revenu le danger pour la démocratie que
pourrait représenter certains des médias
détenus par vincent bolloré et notamment
la chaîne ces news ou eric zemmour avait
pignon sur rue avant d'être candidat à
la présidentielle et sur ce sujet sujet
très politique vincent bolloré a
toujours répondu dans cette audition en
reprenant l'argument de son histoire
familiale écoutez ma famille s'est
battue
vous parliez de là l'après guerre mon
père était dans la résistance d'hier ils
étaient de la classe 22e alors se
soustraire au st lô à l'époque c'était
un peu obligatoire le 6 juin 44 au
débarquement y lit avec 177 français le
général de gaulle a été prévu prévenu la
veille il a dit je veux absolument que
ce soit des français churchill a dégoûté
je crois pas qu'ils aient des françaises
le pas sur il ya 350 mille personnes qui
débarquent il y en a avec 177 sous les
ordres de lord lovât dont deux de ma
famille ma grand mère était au service
action pendant des dizaines d'années en
particulier pendant la guerre et j'ai un
autre oncle dans normandie niemen dos je
crois pas que je vais un adn qui ne
permettent pas dire que je n'aime pas
passionnément mon pays ou que je n'aime
pas passionnément la démocratie voilà
thomas ça fait partie à des extraits un
peu étonnant qu'on a pu entendre dans
cette audition ayant même un moment où
vincent bolloré a sorti de sa poche un
message original du général de gaulle
est créé à son père michel bolloré tout
ça pour dire messieurs les sénateurs je
ne suis pas un ennemi de la démocratie
merci beaucoup merci alexandre plus
rares pour toutes ces explications
j'accueille nathalie sonnac bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes professeur
d'économie des médias à l'université
panthéon assas présidente du comité
d'éthique pour les données d'éducation
et vous avez été membre du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel de 2015 à
2021 donc jusqu'à il ya quelques
quelques semaines j'accueille également
en duplex olivier babeau qui était ces
listes et président de l'institut
sapiens bonsoir olivier babeau bien vous
soit mathieu croissandeau est toujours à
mes côtés et on attend je vous dis tout
en ayant la dent je vous emmène dans
l'arrière cuisine de l'émission on
attend david assouline dont on parlait à
l'instant qui est en train de nous
rejoindre parce que les auditions se
sont terminées et richard sénéjoux
journaliste à télérama qui suivait aussi
l'audition de
de vincent bolloré je reprends je vais
pas refaire l'énumération de de david
assouline mais c'est vrai quand on prend
les regarde un peu lent pire bolloré
dans les médias les chaînes de
télévision la radio europe 1 les
journaux il ya journal du dimanche et
paris match la presse magazine on va
voir sa fiche est de nouveau ces
éléments la dot allison à qu'est ce
qu'un homme d'affaires a déjà eu autant
de levier d'influencé médiatique
potentiellement entre ses mains en
france en tout cas les historiens sont
assez d'accord ils s'entendent pour dire
que depuis 40 50 ans on a une véritable
concentration du secteur médiatique mais
ce qui est vrai en france très largement
et ont observé les raisons certainement
de cette de ce déclenchement de cette
commission des affaires mais dans le
même temps il est vrai que de façon
générale en depuis 20 ans quinzaine
d'années on a un bouleversement un big
bang médiatique avec une recomposition
totale et complète des paysages
médiatiques aux états unis et en europe
et ce mouvement fort de concentration
dans inquiète et aussi des états unis et
une fois encore en allemand en europe
c'était en allemagne en italie en
espagne on observe ces mouvements-là
d'acteurs qui sont extrêmement puissants
économiquement parlant et financièrement
parlant alors la commission
effectivement avec l'audition de vincent
bolloré a bien mis en perspective d'une
certaine façon même si le sénateur
assouline ne le souhaitez pas mais
néanmoins il a mis en perspective qu
est-ce qu aujourd'hui un groupe de
médias en france quelle place ils
occupent dans l'espace de
communicationnel informationnel en
europe et quelle place occupe signé avec
les états unis sans compter qu'on n'a
pas du tout évoqué ou en tout cas en
semble de moments d'exception chinois et
on s'aperçoit que les groupes sont
complètement
transformé on a une industrialisation
réel de ce secteur là ça pose question
ça pose une question clairement
démocratique il faut la repenser et on y
reviendra certainement mais il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui à la fois les outils de
réglementation s qui régule en tout cas
le secteur de l'audiovisuel qui comprend
la télévision et la radio mais qui ne
comprend pas la presse qui ne comprend
pas internet fait qu'on est complètement
décalés ou réguler un secteur qui de
facto s'inscrit dans un ensemble
beaucoup plus large et lui est
totalement ouvert et libre de
circulation donc on voit bien que tout
n'a pas été remis en place
malheureusement lors de la transposition
de la directive des services de médias
audiovisuels l'a récemment la loi 86 a
été 4 modifié 80 85 x et aujourd'hui
elle est vraiment plus en adéquation
obsolète avec ce paysage alors la loi
pas totalement il ya beaucoup d'articles
qui ont été modifiés et justement par
exemple élargissement du champ de
compétences du csa qui devient l'art
comme fait qu'ils rentrent dans son
escarcelle les plateformes de partage de
vidéos les réseaux sociaux et donc ça
c'était important tous les acteurs
aujourd'hui de médias sont aussi des
acteurs de médias en ligne donc
aujourd'hui les smad donc ce qu'on
appelle la vidéo à la demande ou la
télévision de rattrapage rang dans
l'escarcelle de la régulation donc les
regarder mais on voit bien que par
exemple dispositif anti concentration
des médias est lui complètement obsolète
c'est vrai olivier babeau dans les
arguments portés par vincent bolloré
quand il compare son groupe au géant
américain est effectivement il n'a pas
parlé des géants chinois et il reste un
art d'une certaine façon
c'est vrai que et de ces questions on
al'impression
l'économie n'est pas une injonction
contradictoire en europe à la fois on ne
cesse de se lamenter sur l'absence de
géants l'absence de grandes plateformes
qui domine et sur le soft power
étrangers notamment américains ça ça
fait très longtemps mais sur le fait
qu'ils développent de plus en plus et
puis dans un deuxième temps on est
inquiet quand ce type de géant qui
pourtant elle est bien loin commencent à
émerger la vraie question qui se pose en
termes d'ailleurs de deux stratégies
anti concentration et de pensée anti
concentration c'est celle du marché
pertinent c'est quoi le marché pertinent
du média aujourd'hui
le téléviseur la télévision linéaire
l'eau moyenne d'âge c'est plus de 60 ans
la plupart des jeunes en dessous de 30
35 ans ça ne viendrait pas à l'idée de
regarder la télévision en linéaires
c'est à dire avec un programme sur le
moment comme on le faisait autrefois
c'est donc là delà de la
télévision à la demande c'est même
plutôt du contenu à la demande et si on
parle de contenus faut parler évidemment
de youtube il faut parler de netflix
faut parler de ce monde là ils ont on
est plus du tout dans le marché des
médias au sens strict et peut-être une
autre remarque être très inquiet pour la
démocratie ça revient quand même à se
dire que les journalistes que les
rédactions prennent leurs ordres est ce
que c'est vrai moi je pense un peu plus
haut des journalistes et je pense qu'ils
sont capables ou qu'ils soient
d'indépendance et et de et de tenir leur
ligne donc je suis pas très inquiet pour
la démocratie non
richard sénéjoux viennent nous rejoindre
bonsoir bonsoir être journaliste à
télérama et vous assistiez à dition de
chandails de vincent bolloré comment
vous l'avez juge est perçue est ce que
voilà est-ce qu'il a répondu aux
questions un peu botté en touche quand
elle est perçue au jeu contre vincent
bolloré à faire un petit peu le même
numéro qu'ils avaient fait il ya cinq
ans je pense qu'il a pas répondu tout
naturellement sur le fond enfin ni là il
a beaucoup à biaiser rappelé qu' il
n'avait plus de fonctions
opérationnelles au sein du groupe
vivendi effet de route de tous les
médias dont beaucoup voient poser
l'ombre dessus donc
c'est moi je suis resté très sincèrement
sur ma faim est un peu déçu quoi de ces
débats pour aller me cacher sur le
pluralisme et la défense de
l'information selon par les olivier
babeau à l'instant c'est vrai qu'il ya
plusieurs questions là-dessus nenê
notamment de l'inquiétude des des
journalistes du journal du dimanche
il ya eu là le rappel de ce qui s'est
passé hérité il ya quelques quelques
années est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec olivier babeau compte il dit que
finalement faisons confiance aux
journalistes et à leur capacité de
résister à d'éventuelles pressions le
problème c'est que l'histoire n'est pas
favorable à la position vincent bolloré
dont ce qui s'est passé au sein de
groupe canal+ et les médias qui n'a
ensuite dont il a pris ensuite le
contrôle ça a été rappelée donc je vais
peut-être pas le rappeler mais en tout
cas ce qui s'est passé au 110 telle est
la transformation ans et news ce qui
s'est passé sur europe 1 enfin on n'a
pas l'impression que ça tombe de
réellement du ciel donc
l'alternative qui est offert c'est en
gros si on n'est pas raccord avec la
ligne voilà la ligne éditoriale ben
voila vous la voyez sur ces news
maintenant il va vous dire que ce n'est
pas un média d'opinion du chêne
d'opinion qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
chaîne d'opinion si ces news n'est pas
une chaîne opinion pardonnez moi et donc
je pense que ce qui veut être ce qu'il
souhaite insuffler europe 1 c'est un peu
cette même ligne assez
assez dur ultra conservatrice et j'ai
voilà il ya beaucoup de gens d'europe 1
qui ne l'ont pas supporté qui sont
partis olivier babeau un mode réponse là
dessus parce que vous n'êtes pas
fondamentalement d'accord on parle de
pluralisme je suis très attaché
d'ailleurs il ya des candidats qui
réclament la fin du de l'audiovisuel
public
je suis de ceux qui signale que c'est
important qu'il y ait une information
qui soit indépendante des intérêts
privés et à ce titre là évidemment je
défends le des visuels public mais on
peut dire que france inter ou france
culture il faut aussi pour y être collé
à la ligne globale quand même du média
et que finalement les gens qui écoutent
qui suivit peuvent faire leur choix de
la même façon qu autrefois les gens
pouvaient lire le figaro quand il était
plutôt à droite et puis libé quand il
était plutôt à gauche bon bah vous avez
ce pluralisme et ce qui est important
c'est qu'ils aient plusieurs types
d'opinion et puis la capacité des gens à
duffy âmes ans éduquée et avoir du recul
du recul critique pour pour essayer de
picorer en prendre et en laisser un peu
partout je pense que c'est ça ce qui est
sain dans une démocratie évidemment il
faut pas qu'ils aient un seul canal mais
on est très très loin sans jouer mauvais
jeu de mots mais on en est en réalité
extrêmement loin parce que le pluralisme
depuis 15 20 ans grâce à internet en
fait il est là et de façon absolument
écrasante chaque personne devient sa
propre chaîne parce que dans les médias
il faudrait rajouter en fait les réseaux
sociaux vous avez que le grand média
c'est finalement facebook
je reste sur le sur cette idée autour
d'eux notamment de
de ces news du pluralisme et même du
pluralisme globale dans les médias
français
nathalie sonnac vous étiez au csa est
encore quelques semaines je le disais ah
non pardon oui c'était 2021 c'était au
début les
non mais mais merci de faut être précis
on peut effectivement considérer que
l'émergence de ces news c'est une façon
de donner du pluralisme aux médias
français on peut dire ça mais c'est une
lecture si je veux dire ex post le csa
avance aussi en marchant il faut il faut
il faut regarder l'histoire en fait du
paysage audiovisuel et des chaînes de
l'info d'un feu d'information en 2010 en
2005 nous avions jusqu'à 2005 on avait
quelques chaînes qui étaient présentes
chaîne publique chaîne de chaînes
privées et chaînes payantes il ya eu
l'ouverture à la tnt qui a fait arriver
en fait de nouvelles chaînes aujourd'hui
on a 28 chaînes qui sont accessibles
gratuitement avec quatre chaînes
d'information politique et générale si
vous mettez alors on va mettre de côté
la chaîne publique puisqu'elle vit des
subsides de l'état et donc et non pas
des recettes publicitaires on voit que
les trois chaînes sont en concurrence
frontale sur quel marché pas sur le prix
puisque le prix est accessible gratuit
donc le prix 0 pour nous donc son marché
de quoi de la publicité et c'est là le
nerf de la guerre est en concurrence
frontale sur le marché de la publicité
est bien la seule façon de se
différencier c'est d'aller sur les
extrêmes de se polariser
ça a été un choix fait sur ces nous
d'ailleurs un choix
gagnant puisque l'audience à l'audience
a progressé oui parce que partie moment
vous avez besoin de vous différencier il
faut bien trouver le point là me fait
assez intéressant à moi je rejoins
l'analyse et je regrette que finalement
la commission aujourd'hui des sénateurs
ne réfléchissent peut-être pas en ce
sens mais face à un zoom un peu plus
générale aujourd'hui comment les gens
s'informent en fait qu'elle est c'est
plus le marché pertinent du support
c'est le marché pertinent du contenu et
quelle est le marché pertinent
aujourd'hui de l'information et quand
vous êtes un téléspectateur vous êtes en
même temps un auditeur un internaute et
les deux tiers des français en tout cas
des 18 24 ans vont s'informer sur
internet et les réseaux sociaux et 63%
des français s'informent d'abord en
ligne donc la question j'ai pas ces
éléments-là enquête ipsos auprès steria
pour le monde sait de ses récents à sa
date du 3 décembre 2021 quelles sont vos
sources d'informations sur l'actualité
politique alors bon c'est l'actualité
politique en tête c'est encore et
toujours les journaux télévisés ensuite
les chaînes d'information gens utilisent
et 30% chaîne d'information 16% émission
de débat 11% radio réseaux sociaux
presse écrite mathieu
juste on peut pleurer sur la
concentration des médias
faudrait mieux commencer par acheter des
journaux parce que les français à s'être
déjà le problème c'est un problème
d'argent les médias gagne de moins en
moins d'argent parce qu'ils ont de moins
en moins de lecteurs et de moins en
moins de recettes publicitaires et c'est
un mouvement non le moindre aux
électeurs parce que les gens changent
d'habitude de lecture et ont pris
l'habitude de la gratuité parce que les
médias ont fait une bêtise terrible
quand ils sont faits mais reese est il
ya 20 ans par l'apparition du numérique
ça qu'ils ont mis leurs contenus
gratuits parce qu'on ne croyait à
l'époque à la gratuité des nets et ils
ont moins en moins de recettes
publicitaires parce que sont apparus les
gars femme qui siphonnent l'essentiel de
la ressource publicitaire aujourd'hui
donc à partir de là il leur faut quand
même de l'argent parce que l'information
ça coûte cher bien sûr donc comment
finança et comment s'étonner ou plutôt
pourquoi ne pas s'étonner que des
milliardaires viennent tout d'un coup
racheter des entreprises qui ne gagne
pas beaucoup d'argent alors c'est des
gens qui ont beaucoup fait d'argent par
ailleurs et là faut pas non plus se
voiler la face ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans un temps long
en france les milliardaires les groupes
privés ont toujours acheter vous parfois
pour gagner de l'argent quand sans
gagner un peu mais surtout pour avoir
une influence mais s'il ya 20 ans on a
vécu des sociétés adjudicataires marchés
publics qui était propriétaire mais il y
avait des marchands d'eau des marchands
de canons des marchands de bâtiments
ensuite sont arrivés les milliardaires
de luxe ensuite sont arrivés les
milliardaires des télécoms qui sont
aussi par ailleurs
adjudicateur marchés publics notre cas
qui ont besoin de rapports avec l'état
pour acheter des fréquences et des
licences et donc tous ces gens là sont
parfois bien intentionnés parfois
achètent des médailles pour peser sur la
ligne a plus souvent en fait ils
achètent plutôt des médias pour se
protéger ou pour éviter pour les autres
bêtes et puis voilà alors oui
mais parce que là vous pensez vous
pensez médias en fait ce qui coûte
extrêmement cher c'est l'information
elle sur joie complètement mêlée mais la
presse magazine a toujours été
extrêmement rentable la radio et la
télévision led c'est plus le cas
lorsqu'un alors pour la presse de niche
ce n'est plus le cas depuis une dizaine
d'années elle a effectivement depuis
l'arrivée d'internet transformation big
bang médiatique et les gens se déplacent
et donc là où je rejoins complètement
c'est qu'effectivement bien les
annonceurs vont là où sous les lecteurs
les téléspectateurs et donc là où ils
sont et bien c'est en ligne c'est sur
les réseaux sociaux est donc eh bien ils
quittent le marché des médias mais a
quand même en danger mais il faudrait
quand même conseil donne pas
complètement c'est à dire qu'il ya un
danger en matière de pluralisme
démocratique parce que ce que l'on
observe tout de même il ya une étude et
un rapport extrêmement intéressant qui a
été fait par la commission stiegler aux
états unis où on voit bien qu'on est
dans un espace informationnel qui est de
plus en plus large mais qui est
néanmoins de moins en moins démocratique
et c'est ça c'est que la demande de
l'imprimé se déplace vers le numérique
et quel est le danger est bien c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des cantons aux
états unis où nous vous n'avez plus de
presse quotidienne locale et quand vous
n'avez plus de presse quotidienne locale
les gens ne vont votez et ça c'est vrai
aux états unis c'est vrai en allemagne
c'est vrai en italie et il s'avère que
ça devient de plus en plus vrai en
france elle est là l'interrogation je
pense qu'elle est là la question et se
fait de deux à la fois de toujours
réfléchir sur les médias en pensant aux
silos en pensant la presse d'un côté la
radio de l'autre la télévision d'autres
ce n'est plus du tout le cas aujourd'hui
effectivement est d'ailleurs vincent
bolloré le disais c'est le deuxième
secteur le plus riche au monde et disney
c'est pas lui qui l'a inventé c'est une
marque absolument extraordinaire et qui
s'est déployée partout aujourd'hui les
mouvements de concentration sont
extrêmement puissants ils sont partis qu
ils sont horizontaux et son conglomérat
aux états unis notamment on voit des
regroupements des télécoms avec les
contenus et là il faut quand même des
groupes extrêmement puissant en face
pour réagir parce que derrière c'est du
film c'est de la série mais plus
globalement c'est 10 du soft power donc
aujourd'hui en matière de contenu ce sur
quoi il faut quand même s'interroger
c'est qu'il ya quand même un danger
démocratique avec une crise du
pluralisme danger parce que le danger
c'est que les journalistes puissent plus
exprimé faire de l'information faire
l'instigation parce que ça coûte ça
prend du temps ça coûte extrêmement cher
et donc ça il faut les protéger il faut
le renforcer et salades concentration
des médias a quand même cette
implication et ce danger là sur
l'exercice de la profession de
l'information mais pas sur les médias en
général et en même temps on est à un
moment où il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'investigation jamais eu autant enquête
jamais eu autant de reportages au long
cours il ya jamais eu enfin d'autres
autant de choses qui sortent moi moi ce
qui est ce que je trouve paradoxal chez
vincent bolloré c'est qu'il est en train
de construire une machine de guerre de
médiatique de contenus
ultraconservatrice d'ultra droite on
peut l'écouter comme on veut mais que ce
soient pas assumées et on est dans un
pays où on a été alors on a eu la build
une presse d'opinion pour la presse
écrite par exemple est là
dans les médias audiovisuels on est en
france on n'est pas se laisser avoir un
milieu de conventions les canaux et
retient appartiennent à l'état et donc
ben voilà mais vincent bolloré et canal+
signent des conventions avec l'état et
donc d'adam la convention de ces news il
est il ya une impérative de pluralisme
voilà c'est comme ça et c'est le cas
dans toutes les télévisions généralistes
et donc non il peut pas devenir il n'a
pas le droit de venir une chaîne opinion
d'' sa tombe il dit qu'il n'en est pas
une mais en tout cas s'il doit respecter
sa convention et c'est bien pour ça que
le csa a condamné ces news pourra voir
comment diffuser uniquement le les
propos de la france insoumise la nuit
là dessus c'était c'était le 3 décembre
dernier et ses news est mise en demeure
s'est pas encore une sanction pour avoir
diffusé la nuit on est entre minuit et 6
heures du matin c'est pas seulement la
france est soumise à la république en
marche aussi 82 % du volume total 82 %
du volume total des interventions des
membres de l'exécutif qui était diffusée
entre minuit et 6 heures et plus de 53 %
du temps de parole de à des
représentants de la france insoumise
ailleurs vincent bolloré a dû répondre à
une question là-dessus cet après-midi
qu'est ce qu'il a dit eh ben il a
répondu que le nouveau directeur de la
rédaction de ces news n'était pas ma
bretagne n'était pas au courant de cette
obligation de la règle aujourd'hui voilà
exactement de qui voilà donc qui nomme
des gens visiblement qui sont pas
totalement compétent parce que c'est
quand même assez grave ne pas savoir qu'
il ya des horaires particuliers de des
horaires qui pèse plus ou moins lourds à
suivant leur exposition va voilà c'est
le nombre de personnes qui a priori sont
devant voilà tout avait effectivement la
défense un peu un peu faible je pense
que tout le monde peut comprendre qu'à
moins de téléspectateurs qui regardent
entre minuit et 6 heures du matin et à
gaza la télévision montre voilà entre 6h
et 23h bref est ce qu'il ya une volonté
politique de
de vincent bolloré d'après vous c'est
difficile de s'exprimer comme ça lui dit
qu'il n'en a pas moi je vois sur un
spectre politique il est clair que le
sait news en deux ans ne ressemble pas à
itélé qu'elle était auparavant que
clairement ça s'est orientée maintenant
le csa regarde contrôle lorsqu'il a eu
sanctions à m sanctions il ya eu aussi
aujourd'hui ces news ne resta était pas
la convention csa devenu art comme
aujourd'hui sanctionnerait donc je ne
pense pas à ce stade qu'on puisse
qualifier voix la tendance 1 je ne fais
pas du tout la langue de bois on voit
bien la tendance que ça prend mais
aujourd'hui le cess l'art comme pardon
n'a pas sanctionné pour une
contravention delà de la chaîne en tant
que chaîne d'information politique et
générale et effectivement elle a signé
une convention vous vous avez raison
avec des obligations et les règles de
cette convention c'est ça mais c'est une
chaîne d'opinion on peut pas dire le
contraire mais que j'allais les pignons
ayant pignon dans toutes les émissions
qui est asséné sur exactement les mêmes
thématiques avec exactement des idées
convergentes parfois on invite deux ou
trois idiots utiles de l'autre bord pour
donner la réplique est généralement qui
se font et c'est à cela que jean gol qui
seront castanier et parler des batteurs
rient par l'animateur donc qu'est-ce
qu'elle ces saltimbanques alors je vais
je pas d'enjeu dans la presse juste
après un excusez moi mais je vais dire
que évidemment dans ce débat on a invité
les représentants du groupe canal à
venir ou des chaînes du aucun à l'avenir
et ils n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer sur
ce plateau alors je précise aussi que je
ne suis plus membre déjà les a donc
c'est pas au nom du seigneur je suis
présenté ici on ne part évidemment sur
100 mais excellent et que mes ex
collègues mais comprenez la difficulté
en fait que peut avoir le sait c'est
qu'ils regardent ça extrêmement précis
lorsque vous le régulateur intervient ex
ante est c'est à dire avoue que
l'émission a été diffusée je crois qu on
serait tous deux
david assouline si vous terminez votre
phrase on serait tous sur la table en
disant mais mon dieu il y as censure et
on a on peut pas sanctionner avant que
le mal si je vous dirais été fait donc
ensuite aux agents du csa au service de
l'art comme forme si le sénateur aux
agents de l'art comme de s'emparer de
ces questions et de voir si est ce qu'il
ya eu équilibre est ce qu'il ya eu
autant d'invités de droit de part et
d'autre et c'est ce que le pluralisme
est respecté mais il ya un temps
d'instruction qu'il faut aussi laisser
le il n'y a pas une instance comme ça
médiatique ce le rôle du csa il ne peut
le faire qu'en étant posé avec
jurisprudence en regardant les
conventions en regardant si c'est vrai
sur toutes les chaînes parce que l'homme
au zoom sur en fait une ou deux
émissions auxquelles on pense et on
pense tout haut même mais est ce que
c'est la grille de senio est ce que
c'est la grille d'informations sur les
24 heures de ces mots c'est ça que le
sait ça j'imagine simon et dans ses
environs
ça semblait différente vis à vis des
soul merci de nous avoir rejoints ans
avec le timing lettre à lettre il craque
donc bienvenu de danse ans public
qu'elle quel bilan vous faites de cette
audition de vincent bolloré
de toute façon c'est à mettre pour faire
un bilan ça mettre en regard des
objectifs de la commission denquête ans
et deux de poser le débat public de
l'éclairer au maximum et au delà de ce
que lui a pu nous dire ce que nous on a
pu dire et moi en particulier
sont sont aussi intéressants parce que
sur j'ai dû travailler sur ce groupe et
sur les éléments qui peuvent nous
interroger par rapport à
l'activité du groupe bolloré son ampleur
ces
accusations d' intervention sur les
contenus etc donc les choses ont été
dites lui en adipeux mais il apparaît
comme un personnage assez contradictoire
parce que il affiche une décontraction
et une bonhomie
assez assez étonnante en même temps que
les dénégations apparaissent aussi comme
un cynisme absolu donc c'est voilà
est-ce qu'on peut faire les valises une
concentration des médias c'est ça en
fait l'une des questions composer avec
cette commission d'enquêté c'est pour ça
que c'est passionnant c'est est-ce qu
effectivement à la démonstration de
vincent bolloré c'était de se comparer
ou de ce qu'on peut comparer son groupe
au géant américain est ce qu'on peut
faire l'économie d'une concentration des
médias vous allez poser les mêmes
questions au au patron du groupe
bouygues dans quelques dans quelques
jours puisqu'il ya la fusion tf1 m6 qui
se prépare dont je les dis d'ailleurs un
moment donné et ccc récurrent dans nos
de nos auditions
il y a effectivement cette concurrence
des plateformes géant il y a besoin
d'investissements importants dans la
production la formation en france parce
que
c'est une industrie qui coûte cher et
donc
il faut effectivement de l'argent est-ce
que c'est là les concentrations qui
permettent de résister aux la femme je
l'interrogeais d'ailleurs j'ai cité
madame sonné
tout à l'heure dans ce débat en disant
que quand apple tout seul fait 15
milliards par an donc on enlève netflix
amazon extérieur je vous dis parce que
ça fait est que l'ensemble la production
française services publics compris fait
5 milliards en cinq ans on ne parle qu
elle qu'est ce que vient faire une
concentration pour résister à ça pas du
tout donc la réalité ensuite c'est de
voir qu'au nom de cela qu est ce que ça
crée comme dégâts dans la diversité et
le pluralisme dans notre pays et quand
on n'est pas trop inquiet quand même si
on conteste on peut contester la
concentration tf1 m6 mais où on n'est
pas trop inquiet sur
l'interventionnisme la mise au pas des
rédactions mais justement là on a le
symbole d'un alliage des deux quand il
n'ya pas de règle et quand on peut se
concentrer à ce point c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu énuméré la longue liste et on
la rediffuser tout assez fastidieuse
mais ça permet de donner à chacun
l'ampleur de 2,2 dans le monde du livre
on sera obligé de passer par là donc que
si quelqu'un abuse et intervient sur
qu'est ce que l'on a le droit de dire et
pas lire en france eh bien il ya un
sujet et c'est pareil pour l'information
et avec
bolloré on est là dedans il ya une
concentration et on voit un
interventionnisme et un formatage
idéologique et là ça devient très
dangereux mais richard sénéjoux la
question elle se pose aussi pour la
fusion si on va aussi parler un peu des
autres de entre tf1 et m6 notamment sur
les marchés publicitaires
une vraie question est vrai qu'elle est
il faudra savoir quel est le marché
pertinent et précis en tout cas si le
marché bienveillance rs que l'autorité
de la concurrence pendant compte le
marché du digital auquel cas la fusion
poserait pas trop de problèmes ce serait
au sens large ou simplement le marché de
la télévision la pub télé la pub télé
c'est 75 % de parts de marché pour tf1
m6 donc ce qui est une position ultra
dominante mais on peut le dire donc là
il ya cia cette affaire-là et cette
question qui est loin d'être tranchée de
mon point de vue et après moi je
revendique ce que vous dites monsieur le
sénateur s'impose aussi quand même une
question de pluralisme même si a priori
les dirigeants de tf1 m6 sont pas
forcément dans la même on a la même
philosophie ou la même vision
d'information ce que doit être
l'information dans leurs médias que
vincent bolloré le fait de passes qui
fusionne pourquoi c'est aussi pour faire
des économies et donc rapproché des
rédactions rapprocher des locaux c'est
tout ça qui a derrière aussi et donc
pour l'instant on a encore un petit peu
loin c'est dans quelques mois mais quand
les choses vont se préciser où on va oui
avoir des rapprochements physiques dire
que ben voilà on va intégrer la
rédaction de m6 à tf1 que sage et bah
oui est-ce que la couleur de
l'information de m6 qui s'est pas une
chaîne d'info il n'ya pas c'est pas mal
comment la rédaction de m6 est pas du
tout du même niveau que c'est peut-être
de tf1 mais il ya une couleur
l'information il ya une ligne éditoriale
et donc c'est c'est compliqué ça pousse
comme aussi cette question là non mais
bien sûr ça ça je voulais juste dire que
a priori
on nous présente
le problème de la concentration tf6
comme uniquement un intérêt économique
et financier pour faire masse notamment
par rapport à la concurrence nous pose
peu le problème aujourd'hui de
l'interventionnisme quasi caricaturale
que l'on peut voir de l'autre côté mais
bien entendu à partir du dans les
concentrations il y adeux de
l'uniformisation et de la dilution de la
diversité et du pluralisme de l'offre à
chaque fois où le constate déjà dans la
presse écrite et notamment la pqr quand
le groupe ebra
maintient les titres certes sauf que il
ya un bureau à paris qui fait toute
actualité politique nationale sportive
internationale qui a envoyé à toutes les
rédactions au niveau niveau local on ne
peut pas dire que la diversité littoral
qu'il existait et qui existait à travers
tous ces titres est maintenu mais j'ai
aujourd'hui réfléchi et étaient alertés
par des amis qui ont réfléchi aussi là
dessus sur sur cette question du marché
pertinent et y avoir une question très
intéressant que je poserai d'ailleurs
quand on va les auditionner c'est que
l'on me dit que google et facebook sont
tout à fait favorables à cette fusion de
tf1 m6
pourquoi parce que le problème se pose
comme ça pour l'autorité de la
concurrence où on est sur le marché tels
qu'ils existaient et 75% c'est
absolument pas envisageable la
commission européenne à 50% et dit stop
besoin donc cela les obligerait à vendre
donc beaucoup la seule crèche annoncée à
ce que l'autorité de la concurrence va
accepter ce que plaide tf1 m6 et que ce
marché est caduc et qu'il faut intégrer
le numérique et donc si on était le
numérique certains évaluent mais j'ai
pas eu d'étude réel là dessus
l'autorité de le fera à 30% mais
l'effet qu'il y aura c'est que facebook
ou google
vont pouvoir passer à travers les
mailles du filet justement de leurs abus
de position dominante
parce que si on intègre le visuel à ce
marché ils ne sont plus en position
dominante et donc ça les intéresse de
pouvoir avoir une révision du marché
pertinent de cette façon et dont
l'argument c'est de résister aux de la
femme est finalement sont très contents
et ils pourront encore plus échapper à
pau aux abymes killer sur mon corps mes
tournées la fiscalité ou les eaux
hors position de merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat les
auditions continuent évidemment demain
ce sera quand vous atterrissez bernard
zouaoui c'était très intéressant et
c'est un très bon thème de commission
denquête c'est sûrement pour ça qu'on en
parle dans son site merci beaucoup merci
à tous ici et en duplex vous donne
rendez vous demain et puis